you've gone into a position where like
no one knows you you haven't got trust
you're gonna have to establish that how
did you approach that of interest
so twofold really i've always had the
attitude i wouldn't ask anybody to do
anything that i wouldn't do myself it
could be literally anything doing any
kind of awkward calls i was just very
front and center with everything i did
it's really important for me
lead by example show that you're doing
everything believe a lot in that
coaching by being around you know that
environment you see a lot of people walk
off doing in rooms doing those phone
calls either because it gives them more
self-confidence or because they don't
want to be heard whereas i just i always
just did everything as it was and then
the other thing was just i genuinely
really care about people so getting to
know them finding common ground and just
building relationships so i just did
that quite early and i that comes quite
easily to me so just building some trust
within a team and then just being myself
the recruitment mentors podcast is
proudly sponsored by vincerie and the
award-winning sauce breaker